former senior FBI profiler Mary Ellen
O'Toole joins us now she spent more than
20 years investigating mass shootings
and is the director of the forensic
science program at George Mason
University
good morning he had been threatening
this newspaper is far back as 2011 what
clicked what made him go off there
probably was numerous things that that
contributed to his decision to take this
kind of action it would not have been
just one thing so during the course of
his filing that lawsuit and then losing
the appeal in 2013 there were there were
many influences for him you called him a
grievance collector what is that an
injustice collector but a dangerous
injustice collector that's someone who
goes through life it's a behavior that
starts early and they collect and
justices real or imagined throughout
their life the dangerous ones though
respond disproportionately to what
happened to them and this certainly is a
very disproportionate response to what
happened to him CBS News is reporting
that he damaged his fingertips so that
he could not be identified immediately
what does that tell you about him from a
profilers perspective well for one thing
it's very difficult if not close to
impossible to destroy your your
fingerprints because fingerprint
examiner's can still get friction rich
skin from other parts of your your hand
so it tells me he did not investigate
that very well but it also tells me that
that along with not having an ID card he
he wanted to make it difficult for
police stood to identify him
you heard the lawyer for the woman who
was harassed say this was inevitable Tom
mark had an executive editor who the
suspect had said he wished he was dead
this was years ago the police knew that
he had been threatening not only in
person but online and you know
unfortunately there are many people out
there like this guy and him he stepped
over the line and right now anymore
we're seeing more and more people who
are like this who are being fueled by
things that appear in Twitter and who
and appear online that are really fueled
and it really helps contribute to their
making that decision to act out police
found the suspect hiding under a desk
I read that what does that say about his
personality to things that suggests to
me that he may want to he may have
wanted to blend in with the rest of the
people there and walked out that was his
way of evading that it could have been
all right there and also one other thing
usually we in these mass shootings we
have a semi-automatic rifle he had a
pump-action shotgun two possible reasons
for that a pump-action shotgun is just a
terrifying weapon it's it doesn't it
doesn't produce as much lethality but
perhaps he was concerned he was not able
to purchase an automatic rifle and
that's why he fell back to the
pump-action shotgun
Mary Ellen O'Toole thank you so much for
joining us you're welcome now let's send
it back to Gail in New York Gail Thank
You Nora so it admire the people at the
newspaper that said we are still putting
out a damp paper tomorrow you know when
you think of as you said at the top of
the show this is a deadliest attack of
journalists in US history you don't
think that you're in danger when you go
to your job you think if you're covering
a war area maybe you're covering a very
domestic situation maybe you don't think
you're in danger just going to your
office every day that's why this is so
troubling troubling indeed and why you
saw many of the news organizations step
up their police presence certainly in
New York in the Washington DC area in
light of this all right thank you very
much Nora I don't think it helps either
to have the President of the United
States saying that the media is an enemy
of the people especially to lead to one
of the deadliest local newspapers like
this are the heart and soul that's all
right these this newspaper was founded
in the 1700s it's not about response and
you heard the police yesterday say we
know these reporters we know them when
we like them thank you very much Norah
O'Donnell